la fibre optique pour tous en 2021 sur
saint quentin en yvelines c'est
l'objectif de l'opérateur orange les
opérations démarrent cette année pour
avoir une couverture totale sur la
verrière et trappe d'ici à deux ans
situation identique à villepreux avec
l'ensemble des foyers fibrés en 2021
le réseau fibre est quasiment cinq fois
plus petit que le réseau cuivre au point
de vue sur phase d'installation qui
permet enfin de compte d'alimenter une
zone jusqu'à 20 kilomètres autour les
fibres qui vont toucher les clients pour
être capable d'être utilisé par tous les
opérateurs qui le souhaitent et vont
pouvoir les clients bretons pouvoir
prendre l'opérateur qui souhaite pour
pouvoir avoir les services qu'ils
souhaitent aussi elancourt plaisir
maurepas et voisins le bretonneux toutes
ces communes bénéficient déjà de la
fibre optique sfr s'est occupé à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines uniquement de
la ville de montigny le bretonneux avec
la possibilité pour les clients de
savoir s'ils peuvent bénéficier de cette
technologie
alors nous avons différents sites
d'information sur internet que vous
pouvez consulter et qui vous indiquent
que la fibre et dans votre ville la
fibre et dans votre quartier la fibre et
dans votre rue le dispositif sera
installé à la fin de l'année à
guyancourt magny les hameaux et
coignières pour les clayes-sous-bois ce
sera en 2020 actuellement 400 mille
logements sont éligibles à la fibre
optique dans les yvelines